[Musica]
all
impostazioni
tempo di utilizzo
una media giornaliera tra le 4 e le 8
ore
intere giornate praticamente
nell'antica grecia invece si
trascorrevano intere giornate a teatro
per assistere alle tragedie o alle
commedie era un vero e proprio rito e
aveva anch'esso una funzione politica
sociale culturale
culturale vale a dire proprio religiosa
è difficile parlare di teatro in un
momento storico in cui siamo votati al
devotissimo culto della tecnologia
niente di più lontano dal teatro e
niente di più intangibile del teatro
quante volte ci capita scorrendo sui
nostri social di imbatterci in quei
video interminabili e magnetici che ci
mostrano gli incredibili disegni
dell'effetto domino con i pezzettini che
cadono tu sei lì sei magari in ritardo
sai che non potresti perdere tempo
sai che dovresti fare cose fare altro
studiare lavorare lavarti uscire e
cucinare eppure rimani lì
incantato anzi incastrato davanti a quel
video e non puoi smettere cioè non poi
provi proprio una specie di di fastidio
nel petto allo stesso tempo una goduria
malsana e no non smetteresti mai di
guardare coi pezzi cadere a catena e
allo stesso tempo tutto ciò che vuoi è
vedere come va a finire che niente va a
finire che i pezzi cadono tutti ma il
punto è lo tolgo perché
quasi inutile in questo momento scusate
come cadono questi pezzi e come cadono
oggi sarà diverso da come cadrebbero
domani
non parlo della traiettoria esatta che
ci si augura sia sempre quella giusta a
beneficio del disegno finale ma parlo
dell'urto di ogni singolo tassello la
sua singola caduta sarà sempre uno
spettacolo differente
e a teatro e così è esattamente così
ogni sera è diverso perché ogni sera è
unica ogni sera al teatro uno spettacolo
nasce e muore lì e non esiste una
replica
perfettamente esatta di uno spettacolo
teatrale perché il teatro è fatto di
castelli vivi
composti da o mossi da persone esseri
umani soggetti dunque a delle emozioni e
delle condizioni corporee alle azioni e
reazioni
relazioni con i suoi interlocutori che
siano essi colleghi il reparto tecnico o
semplicemente il pubblico
il teatro è qui e ora esattamente come
l'effetto domino
ora noi quei video sul cellulare li
possiamo stoppare mandare avanti
indietro possiamo velocizzarli
addirittura ma avete mai provato ad
alzare il volume di quel video avete mai
ascoltato lo stupore infantile
l'adrenalina
l'incontenibile emozione di un pubblico
presente che assiste alla caduta dei
tasselli in un effetto domino onlive
alzate il volume
e fate in ascolto
io vi assicuro che il suono è lo stesso
di un pubblico che assiste vive reagisce
ad un bello spettacolo
ma quanto amore quanta cura maniacale
nel sistemare ogni singolo tassello è la
stessa che ci vuole per consegnare al
pubblico uno spettacolo ben confezionato
che funzioni che abbia un ritmo che
stupisca che tenga lo spettatore lontano
da dove ha parcheggiato la macchina e li
inchiodato col fiato sospeso ad
aspettare il resto
e se è vero che ci vuole una cura
maniacale
e vero anche che bisognerà senz'altro
avere qualche mania anzi vi dirò di più
bisognerà pure essere un po maniaci
scegliere di vivere di questo di quello
che per la società non è un mestiere
normale e in effetti non lo è il regista
l'attore è straordinario nel senso che
extra ordinario
e non ha percorso i canonici
non si viene inseriti in un albo e si è
continuamente soggetti al gusto
artistico o peggio estetico
e non conosce feste non conosce lutti
non conosce that talk non esistono
previsioni né a breve ea lungo termine
io non ero affatto sicura di poter
essere qui stasera a parlare a voi nella
meravigliosa cornice della mia città in
questa mattina ero sul set da un'altra
parte ad interpretare un altro
personaggio diverso da quello che sto
interpretando adesso diverso da me
[Applauso]
non so quale lavoro prenderò perderò tra
un mese non so chi interpreterò
nella vita degli attori una cosa è certa
l'incertezza ci domina
dominare la scena non è la parte più
complessa della vita di un attore e ciò
che un attore vorrebbe sempre fare
dominare il palco lo si può fare con un
po di tecnica con un po di studio e
sicuramente con moltissimo cuore ma a
dominare la vita che c'è fuori dal palco
è la cosa più dura e dominare la vita
che questo mestiere ti fa fare i suoi no
i suoi forse che spesso sono peggio dei
no e quello è il vero mestiere
domare e dominare per non essere
dominati dominati dal confronto
dall'aspettativa dall'attesa
come si fa
facendo il proprio due mine facendo pace
con il fatto che ognuno il proprio
percorso perché ogni attore lavora con i
propri attrezzi del mestiere che sono il
suo corpo la sua voce il suo cuore la
sua mente e la sua storia
e così sono diversi alunni dagli altri
facendo il proprio con i propri
strumenti
i miei strumenti ad esempio mi hanno
portato ad esplorare l'insegnamento a
mio modo credo il più concreto fare il
mio ed è diventato è diventato
trasmettere la poetica teatrale ai
giovani ei giovanissimi a quelli che
rischiano di dimenticare o di non sapere
mai che esiste un qui e ora e che le
emozioni no quelle non si possono
stoppare o mandare avanti o indietro
dumaine fare il mio per me seminare
raccogliere
seminare ancora andare lontano
ritornare e riportare a casa com
[Applauso]